what's up Internet welcome to the hind
the scenes for this video welcome to the
behind the scenes for the video you just
watched usually come with names for
videos at like 5:00 a.m. the day I'm
uploading it's not 5:00 a.m. yet so you
don't get a name yet so we missed the 5
and deadline still don't have a title
don't even have a finished video so
every once in a while an idea for video
comes along that's completely inspired
by some really cool effect we've learned
or figured out and as you can probably
tell this one is freezing people and
turning them into 3d models so there's a
program out there called reconstruction
which let's use an Xbox Kinect to scan
in 3d models of objects and people it's
really cool and it works perfectly for
making a statue of somebody frozen in a
pose so I took that and made people this
concept like Medusa style action see
where people get frozen into statues and
then shattered using a program called
ray Fire you probably have never heard
of that you've probably heard it ever
multiple times on videos it's pretty
sweet we know this one Beach that's
surrounded on all sides by cliffs it's a
great shooting location because you can
only get to it by climbing over a bunch
of rocks yeah it's a secret we can't
tell you where it is though apparently
most Californians don't like climbing
over rocks so it's really just us
they're the tired a most like I want one
or two other adventures yeah there's so
many cool things there you got like
wildlife you got like dolphins you got
sea lions
you got her pelicans Birds of all shapes
and sizes it's amazing and so it kind of
interrupts the shoot because you're
basically like half at the zoo and half
on a film set like all day so that's
really cool but it's a nice change of
pace from the dusty city that we usually
see shooting so yeah we usually suit in
a suit dusty city that we suit in
whatever it was that was that supposed
to be funny so as you guys can tell they
show a lot of our stuff during the
daytime so we can use the sunlight to
light the scene that way tend to look
around a bunch of lights and find
electricity at all kind of stuff you got
about 10 hours or so maybe twelve until
kind of wrap it up and you're gonna be
forced to wrap them so I think there's
actually the earliest YouTube video
we've ever woken up for because we got
to the location at 7:00 in the morning -
like just maximize our daylight out
there so yeah I think it out minute like
2 a.m. 3 + 25 10 that's the usual
schedule around here it's just me and
Coty this is just really had no idea
they were filming I just have to I come
out here wherever just rolled up this is
how I usually run the beach in Malibu
right so we're do and I mean I run to
this guy he's taking a grave somewhere
kind of creeping me out a little bit but
uh well you know what where they say
knock him dead I'm just making the plots
getting ready to kill them all so yeah
whatever whatever he said so for this
idea Nico's like hey we should make it
like it's all like in the 50s an old
timey and like listen you can't just do
that he's like yeah hold on let me get
some real actors in here yeah
so we talked to a friend sad-looking
Cote of course uh Jake Watson makes
another appearance as he does in almost
all our videos yeah
and this time is my turn - ah dis Mak
ting so I jumped in and same chocolate
fresh fresh and fresh and dirty I'm just
switch lenses right away
10 don't you want to go far back and
compress the space do it
that I think what we should do here and
this will even work with the two shots
damn plan and showing the statue is we
need a shot before that one of us their
eyes closed like kind of peeking out
because we need we need everybody to
shut it everybody's eyes are closed we
haven't revealed what happened yet and
someone peeks out and so it's like what
do they see cuts to what they see you
know Wilson rules
anyways just want to say thanks to Zach
Cody
coming out and taking the time guys yeah
I'm really appreciate it can't we go do
more stuff with you thanks for letting
us download your models into the
mainframe thank Jake but we say that
everyone go head sounds weird and hates
Eagles so the word Chloe used here for
the models as first took her actors
stand with in with the Kinect we tried
to make it as good as possible meaning
no holes
the actor had to hold as still as
possible so I think that shift will get
all weird and no matter what there's so
many little holes he has going to a mesh
so if you guys can play this program
I'll reconstruct what you probably are
yes I recommend it just be aware you go
outside you try to do it outside the Sun
is blasted mega infrared beams your
Kinect is only blasting like mini
infrared beams we were on the beach
we're gonna capture all our actors their
poses so yeah we're not gonna have to
drive all the way back home through like
two hours of traffic just to film this
little 3d model wrong wrong we did
because the Sun was blasting too many
rays and it was interfering with the
Kinect sensor so anyways after we had
the 3d capture of the models we had them
in the computer or set up the scenes
through our motion tracking doing some
sweet fracturing I talked to a friend of
ours named Enzo he helps develop Rafe
our along with pyrimidine testing and
other cool stuff he has his own VFX
company and based out of New Orleans he
helped us out with a couple shots I want
to say thanks and some huge
huge huge huge dude
huge thanks thanks huge thanks you did
fantastic work anyways guys we've been
working hard trying to get everything
figured out so you could put out more
behind-the-scenes content and more
second channel videos on a more regular
basis and this is going to get started
that so you guys haven't subscribed for
a second channel which is what you're on
right now
I highly suggest it it's a good life
decision if you don't do it you'll
probably get stupid and forget
everything smart don't want that
happening but whatever I'm here listen
was it Internet is there
listen internet someone just literally
stealth their way behind us and walked
into our kitchen anyways guys that's it
hope you liked the video another one in
two weeks on our main channel and you
model stay tuned here on the second
channel also cool stuffs coming she
doing Sam I bug bites in a suspicious
pattern on my legs I is that going to go
in the video are hundred thousand
dollars
you